[Musique]
il y à 50 ans le premier courriel
annonce le début d'une révolution
c'est en novembre 1971 ou peut-être en
décembre en fait rieter une seule ne
souvient pas de la date exacte et il ne
se doutait pas qu'il passera à
l'histoire
[Musique]
comme
à l'époque rick hansen est un jeune
ingénieur qui travaille pour une firme
un peu obscur mais il est au bon endroit
au bon moment
dans les années 60 les ordinateurs sont
très rares et surtout très cher pour les
rentabiliser
les chercheurs se départagent sur
différents quarts de travail
on invente alors le concept de messages
électroniques entre les utilisateurs
d'un même appareil l'émetteur dépose son
message dans un dossier sécurisé auquel
seul le destinataire accès c'est le
premier ingrédient du futur courriel
en parallèle l'armée américaine finances
le tout premier réseau informatique
arpanet permet aux universités et aux
centres de recherche de partager à
distance
l'utilisation des ordinateurs mais aussi
d'échanger des fichiers et c'est
l'entreprise où travaille tomlinson qui
développe ce réseau il va combiner les
deux idées pour envoyer des messages par
le biais d'un réseau
il ne manque qu'un détail comment
identifier à la fois le destinataire et
son ordinateur
ray tomlinson analyse son clavier et
choisit la touche la moins utile de tout
le commercial ces caractères qui
risquent le moins de se retrouver dans
le monde des gens ou des appareils
le temps lenssen échange son premier
courriel avec lui-même entre deux
ordinateurs situés dans la même pièce
merlier uniquement pas raison
le contenu ne passera pas à l'histoire
quelque chose comme quoi diop ou
peut-être testing 1 2 3 4
là encore ray tomlinson ne s'en souvient
plus très bien chose certaine le tout
premier courriel serait probablement
considérée aujourd'hui comme du courrier
indésirable